you're in the prelinger library in San
Francisco and South of Market one of our
biggest group of users in the library or
what Meghan called food futurists they
love this place because we've got a
tremendous library of historical AG
stuff and a lot of it as bad ideas and
you know our libraries greatest
strengths as bad ideas outdated
information things where you can look
back and you can say oh okay we may not
know a whole lot but at least we know
this is wrong Tess it's really important
to utilize history as a tool for opening
up the future and part of that is
dissolving the sense of the immediacy of
the present I think what we're trying to
do is bring some sense of you know
historical consciousness to the amnesic
present we see this as a historical
intervention where we inject the
documents the artifacts of the past into
the present so as to affect the future
what's the texture of near history it's
not going to be determined by the big
ideas of 200 years ago it's going to be
determined by the detritus of yesterday
and what's remembered and what's
rejected from what happens 10 and 20
years ago both of our work is founded
around trying to understand what the
meaning of historical ephemera is we
don't start with the great philosophers
of the great theorists we start from the
bottom of or from the scraps up